hey everyone welcome back my name is
mehul and in this video i'm gonna share
my 10 productivity hacks with you in vs
code and mind you this is not a list of
10 simple keyboard shortcuts which
pretty much are very common and everyone
knows but actual 10 productivity hacks
which i see a lot of people are missing
out so let's watch all of them in this
one video if you're new here make sure
you like the video and subscribe to the
channel i will share a lot of such
productivity tips tricks and hacks and
in general about web development i share
that all the time so if you want to
receive notification make sure you're
subscribed and hit the bell icon alright
tip number one is multi-route workspaces
i'm gonna give you a real world example
of me working with code damn so goddamn
you know has a front-end index js and a
back-end in graphql so most of the times
whenever i'm working with front-end and
it requires some sort of api work i need
to work with back-end as well it's a bit
hard to manage two folders to vs code
instances so what you can do is if you
also have multiple such folders open the
command palette and write a command
saying workspaces add a folder to
workspace so just write add folder to
workspace and this should isolate this
command so the moment you do that if you
hit enter you will see vs code actually
asks you for this particular folder
which should be the next folder and
right here you can select let's say in
this case backend and when i add this
you can see there's a weird icon
appearing here which is like a radio
button sort of thing and when you close
up close both of them they both kind of
get selected but the point here is now
even though they are they might not be
in same directory in this case they are
but you have access to both of them
right so the search would work fine the
terminal would work fine so one neat
thing you can see here is that if i am
in a folders file of code down next
let's say and if i start the terminal i
start with the code down next terminal
but if i am in a backend file for
example if i am in this folder i have
this file open and if you try to open
the terminal in this folder you will see
it starts from the back end as the root
directory so that's pretty neat but
anyway that's the trick you can add
multiple folders here and you can even
name your workspace something so that
you can just restore this anytime you
want to just start working with the same
tech again the second tip which i have
is to use github copilot now github
co-pilot is a extension which you can
install by going to extensions right
here and writing copilot and you have to
get access for this from github but once
you do that it's basically it says that
it's an ai pair programmer and it truly
is i mean in some cases github co-pilot
is very powerful it can do very simple
things like write a function to add two
numbers it could do simple tasks like
this or it could do complex tasks like
saying create a platform for interactive
coding learning and as you can see
github co-pilot just created code damn
source code so it's pretty awesome i
mean if you ask me it can just bootstrap
your whole startups and companies well
not yet but it's possible over the next
few years so make sure you keep an eye
and an extension on it the third tip
which i have for a lot of people is try
to use the command palette more what do
i mean by that if you press let me just
go ahead and actually start the
developer screencast mode first of all
so you can see what i'm pressing if you
press command p on the screen you can
see that i have this panel where i have
the ability to navigate between these
files right with arrow keys but the
moment you write this greater than sign
or less than sign i don't know what you
call this but the moment you write this
you would see all of the files are gone
now and these all are commands so this
symbol right here just means that you
are trying to run a command and pretty
much everything you are thinking you can
do a lot of most of the things i won't
say everything but most of the things
you can do from here for example hide
the sidebar
like this for example reload the window
so you can reload the whole vs code
window as well if you want like this and
continue with your work so you can see
apart from reload there are a bunch of
very useful commands here which you can
write and a lot of extensions just plug
into this as well so if you have a bunch
of extensions maybe you will also find
commands for that but yeah it's a it's a
handy uh area to be in it's almost like
a mini google for you inside of escort
that what you want to do with your text
editor you can pretty much ask it
anything you want right you can also say
something like select all if you are
feeling lazy and you know you don't want
to press command here control or
whatever all right tip number four is
paint tabs in vs code now i'm sure you
know about pin tabs in chrome or any
browser but do you know that you can
also pin tabs in vs code and one of the
best things about this is once you pin
tab by clicking right clicking on this
and doing this pin with command k or
shift enter or just using this menu the
moment you do that you can see the cross
is no longer appearing here instead pin
symbol appear here and the command w
just stops working right so the command
w is not closing this tab in instead it
just moves to the next file right so let
me just again toggle the screencast mode
on and if i click this command w you can
see nothing is happening so that is
awesome let's say you have a bunch of
important files in a swarm of files
which you have opened the pin tab first
of all would keep it uh you know at the
at the very beginning if you try to
rearrange it you can see that it just
removes the pin so that is awesome and
the second thing is that it would not
allow you to close the file so that is
again awesome sometimes i'm just on a
streak of pressing this command w right
and it's possible that you just pretty
much close every file and the editor
itself as well so just pin a couple of
files which you think are important and
just work really my fifth tip is to
actually go ahead and review your github
pull request directly from vs code and
this is very convenient because to be
honest personally i don't like how the
github pull request feature works in the
sense you have two windows with a split
where the lines are cut off and all that
stuff it gets messy so if you have an
editor that's a much better way to
review a pull request the core part so
what you have to do is go ahead and
install this github pull request and
issues extension and the moment you do
that you will see a nice little icon
which appears here and when you click on
it if you are inside an active git
repository which is connected to an
origin as well you're gonna see all the
open pull requests so in this case i
just have one and i can just go ahead
and review all the changes directly from
my editor now don't actually go into
font size here because obviously i've
zoomed in for the video purpose but it
looks pretty nice you get the control uh
you clearly see what's the difference
between old and new and you pretty much
have access to the full file right if
you want to just compare something super
handy extension i believe every code
reviewer or every person who reviews you
know their own work or maybe somebody
else's work in a startup in a company
this extension is a must because it will
help you speed up the pull request a lot
you don't have to have
a lot of jumping around or context
switching which probably happens when
you're doing it from the web ui my sixth
tip is to actually use vs code for
refactoring purposes as well so for
example let's say you want to rename
this function something else and you
don't want to just go to every single
individual file this could very well be
a variable this could be a function like
in this case this could be anything all
you have to do is press the function key
and f2 and this little menu would appear
if it doesn't work for some reason just
right click and locate this rename
symbol thing right so the moment you do
that you're going to be seeing
this enter to rename and enter to
preview stuff and you can just say my
email sender function
for example and when you do that you can
see every single file which had that got
it changed right now all you have to do
is to save all of these files which i
mean i'm just combining two productivity
tips in one so the the way you do it is
a you can sure go to every single tab
and press command s or ctrl s or you can
go to your command panel
hit this command line and write save all
right so you can see save all also has a
shortcut with command k and s right you
can memorize this shortcut but you'll
only be able to memorize it once you
start using it more and more right so if
you're doing it every once in a while i
mean it's fine you can just pretty much
ignore it right but anyway once you do
that you can see all of the files are
saved together which is pretty handy
even if you're doing you know any other
sort of refactoring which changes all
the files and is waiting for you
vs code is waiting for your approval to
do that my seventh productivity hack is
to actually not go ahead and just close
and open your vs code window all the
time i mean vs code is
built on chromium and it provides a
bunch of useful features which includes
like performing a hot reload and a
basically full reload as well without
actually closing the parent process so
let's say you are modifying your
typescript file and you see that some
changes are not reflected right so you
can selectively reload those parts of
the vvs code application the way you do
that is you again go to command palette
and write restart
typescript server right and i haven't
like configured a shortcut i don't think
there is a shortcut anyway this is
something you don't need to do a lot so
no need to have a shortcut but the
moment you write restart typescript it
will show up and you can do this you're
going to see at the bottom it will say
you initializing jsts language features
and that's how you know that it's
restarting the typescript server
sometimes it might happen when you're
modifying some ps config file or maybe
some eslint file as well so if you
modify this some changes might not
reflect so you can just go and say
restart
eslint for example right here and it
just restarts the eslim server for you
this is pretty handy in case something
is broken or something is not working in
the vs code itself you can just say
reload the window itself so it just
reloads the full window right which
again is mostly equivalent of closing
and opening the vs code there might be
few edge cases but for the most part
this would work without you actually
just closing the whole project and you
know doing all that stuff my eighth tip
for you is reopening the last close tab
sometimes it might happen when you're in
speed you just randomly close the tab
right randomly close a couple of tabs
the moment you do that you can actually
restore your tabs by pressing command
shift t which might be ctrl shift t if
you're on windows and if you keep doing
that vs code would just you know start
undoing what it has done in terms of
closing the tabs so again this is super
handy sometimes because when you're on a
streak to close all these tabs you might
see that you just missed and closed a
couple more so this is much much better
when you have i mean when you have a lot
of files and folders and hierarchy so
instead of just finding that exact piece
of file which you just close just do
this my number nine tip for you guys is
to actually take a look at how you can
move code in vs code pretty quickly i
have seen people doing stuff like this
so if i want this to appear above this
i'm gonna control x this go here hit
enter a couple of times and press ctrl e
this is the grand mamo right the hacker
move is the following so you select the
bunch of text which you want to move
somewhere in the document and you press
the option key it might be alt key in
your case press the option key and start
moving it with arrow keys arrow up or
down right so you can see right here as
you are moving it through it can
actually pass through various code
blocks as well so that is pretty neat
right so if you just want to move it at
the top you do something like this enter
a bunch of lines and you're done right
and it's a super fast super speedy way
to actually move your code across you
can move as much code as you like and
you know every other code piece would
actually adjust on the document super
useful hack if you're trying to refactor
a core base if you're trying to do
something some cleanups and this would
really help and my final tip for you is
to use regular expressions when you're
using vs code when you're trying to find
and replace something this is not always
helpful but when it is required then it
becomes very very handy so for example
let's just imagine you have a csc file
with thousands of records and you want
to do something very specific in terms
of finding and replacing instead of
writing a script to do that for you you
can very well just use a regular
expression which you can toggle on by
pressing this dot star thing which just
toggles up the regular expression mode
that means now this find field would
actually act as a regular expression
field right which will match against
this file so let's say in this file i
just want to add a new line after every
single line which contains at least an l
right you can see this line has an l
this line has an l this line has an l
this line has an l so the way to do that
would be something like this so you
write an l which is not a regular
expression but what you do is that you
say that hey just lazily match anything
in that l until i get a new line so you
can see right now vs code has returned
the following matches
which you can see ignores the something
and yo which does not contain an l so
the moment you do that you can have
let's say i want an l
but also replace whatever you have
matched against and with a couple of new
lines now right so the moment i do that
replace you can see that pretty much
works exactly how i wanted it to just
after every single line with a new line
i just want a new another line for that
so regular expressions are powerful if
you don't know the basics of them i
would probably create a crash course on
them so maybe we'll link it after this
video once that video is created but
yeah i mean this is this is powerful
stuff and it has saved me countless
hours i wouldn't say like tens of hours
but definitely a few hours over the last
few years right so try learning about
regular expressions and how you can make
use of them in your find and replace
things all right so that was all about
my 10 productivity vs code tips what do
you think i missed which one is your
favorite do let me know in the comments
below if you like this video make sure
you like and subscribe send it to your
friends that really helps keeping a lot
of content here at a high quality for
free i hope you enjoyed this and i'm
gonna see you in the next video really
soon
[Music]